de quoi voulez pas un petit cochon d'été
au chaud le petit cochon on vient de le
voir vous avez refusé de le montrer non
non non non on l'a vu et n 18
non mais on n'y a eu qu'un petit cochon
et une petite chanson le plateau on est
désormais je vous il a été montré alors
comme les images je vais vous dire
pourquoi le montrera parce qu'il ya des
règles en télévision exacte est on est
en direct donc on l'a montré au début et
vous savez on peut pas montrer comme ça
des animaux morts il ya des enfants qui
nous regardent il ya déjà des parents
aussi
il ya des essais des images un peu
choquant et on ne peut pas montrer
toutes les images il ya le csa christine
kelly aucun des partis et je pense c'est
une image et qu'on peut pas montrer
qu'il me rappelle très bien de ce moment
là on l'a on a dit qu'on ne faisaient
pas d'un gros plan parce que ça avait
surpris tout le monde c'était un un coup
journal europa
je veux dire alors allez diadeis ce qui
est choquant c'est surtout vitrine bon
c'est quoi ce qui ce qui est rien les
vitrines la résistance animalistes avons
fait une promesse à ce petit porcelet
qu'il ne serait pas mort pour rien
balances ton post n'est ce pas alors oui
balancer maintenant votre poste l'acte
neufs commence maintenant plus jamais
les ports ne seront balancés action
directe de justice maintenant sur
boucherie absolution alors là vous êtes
en bourse ou quoique teneur en direct
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rien contre vous et je comprends
tout ça est votre constat mais juste
anaïs là on a l'impression que vous
donnez des codes direct chez les sous
entendus cautionner elle est passionnée
elle est très émue que c'est écoutez là
ce qu'elle dit est important mais pour
une fois toujours d'accord avec tout ce
que j'ai gardées secrètes et un mort
c'est un peu paradoxal quoi alors comme
ça
anaïs alesi nom m'a dit plus que votre
théorie potes notre message est
important mais hannah murray en est vrai
que les téléspectateurs le comprennent
ne lisez pas analyse par les libres aux
mains et non mais vous êtes le message
le message est très très claires prises
le message est très clair à nos élus
action tout le direct maintenant aux
actions illégales sur boucherie
absolution maintenant absolution
maintenant sur le facebook du free
abolition actions illégales insurrection
maintenant désobéissance à cyril enfin
maintenant résistance animalistes en
actions maintenant collision
[Applaudissements]
voilà eurent un petit événement avec
cette jeune fille anaïs qui est voilà
qui fait partie d'un mouvement vegan il
voulait faire une action en direct
qu'ils ont filmée sur facebook c'est
aller dans un abattoir pour aller donc
kidnappé un cochon voilà m elle n'était
pas du tout violent de sachez le elle
est là juste je voulais juste montrer
une pour une
voilà une peau car tout voilà une locale
pour venir anaïs montrer votre truc
voilà juste et dites nous ce que vous
voulez faire boucherie abolition yahoo
voilà c'était sur facebook parce que
voulait lancer un appel sur un facebook
live c'est ça je voulais je vous tienne
votre micro
voilà merci il n'y a rien de violent ça
chez nous parce que c'est vrai que ça a
été un petit peu rapide et voilà on a
cru qu'anaïs voulais m'attaquer mais
anaïs n'était pas du tout là dedans
voilà elle voulait juste me protéger un
peu plus son millionnaire venez venez
l'analyse comme ça qu'on voit bien votre
truc est donc dit waouh est très court
alors il est tout simplement je ne suis
pas là pour débattre on ne sensibilisent
part à l'holocauste c'est pas pour
contre le massacre coup contre tuer pour
contre le viol raciale
c'est votre définition de low cost alors
exactement c'est un être innocent ratio
pay pay s'il vous plaît ce que
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête avec ces
mots ou est-ce qu'il ya des gens
vraiment qui est qu'ils peuvent pas en
tant que ça c'est très grave et on peut
pas faire cet amalgame là voilà je vous
dise qu'on dit en premier bien sûr que
la comparaison
cette comparaison c'est pas nous qui l'
abandon oui non mais ça vient quand même
2 ça a été écrit dans un livre collectif
va rester c'est oui ben justement tous
les cas votre combat voilà je vous le
dis je peux le comprendre ce qu'on
prouve aussi été débouchées qui ont
envie de travailler mais juste à les y
voilà c'est jusqu'à des mots qui peuvent
choquer surtout en direct à la table des
noës à sauver le monde en sauvant les
animaux compte en milliards de morts
on parle de 2 milliards de morts chaque
année
alors qu'elle est née à nice moi je
laisse la parole parce que je laisse la
parole à tout le monde ici soyez sony ce
calme et tranquille je me laisserais la
parole loto qu'il faut j'ai fait passer
votre message et dites moi ce qui se
passe comme je les dis c'est très simple
on ne court une fois on ne sensibilisent
pas aux massacres qu un d'être innocent
qu'on fait naître pour tuer on ne
sensibilisent pas l'holocauste ce débat
non non ce débat non non eddehbi voilà
bon bah merci
elle a fait passer son message merci
anaïs voilà mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
pas faire ce genre de comparaison est
vraiment ce que c'est c'est par la voix